[Music]
with the abrupt
ending to shin godzilla a creature that
showed so much promise for total
annihilation
the audience was left with an edge for
more the movie which was made in an
unofficial
protest towards the slow reaction
regarding the fukushima nuclear disaster
focused again on godzilla emerging from
the ocean to destroy japan
and this time it was a different take on
the kaiju shin godzilla was evolution
incarnate he was supposedly an ancient
sea life form that was exposed to
radiation
and radioactive waste dumped by the
united states and he kept on evolving
until he became
a 118.5 meter tall kaiju
so according to the art of shin godzilla
and several other official publications
the fourth form was merely a beginning
baby
and godzilla would continue to evolve
future forms and consequences of this
have been noted and it was pointed that
extinction on the sub-cellular scale is
necessary
to defeat godzilla and that the blood
coagulant was just a temporary measure
something that was easily overcome by
godzilla who was evolution itself
so in this video we will discuss all the
eight forms
that shin godzilla was theorized to have
and by the end of it
it will leave you shocked as to what he
will become so let's go step by step
till we get to the final stage the
pre-form
godzilla is not born out of the dropping
of a nuclear bomb
but rather out of nuclear waste dumb in
the sea godzilla like most other
monsters if not all
is a monster that humans make directly
or indirectly
we learn it was created when a marine
animal consumes nuclear waste dumb
by the united states in the sea once
again nuclear wastes and victims
lie at the origin of godzilla these
marine animals were
ancient sea life forms that continued to
exist till the present day
and this origin was similar to that of
this deroya
the first form the first form is never
physically seen in the film aside from
its tail and part of its back
the tail is reddish in color while its
back discovered in tan dorsal fins
and while the art behind chin godzilla
shows that the first form was a deadpool
like creature that had two legs that
were very primitive in looks
the head kind of resembles a frog but
with very large gills coming out from
the side
it is seen to have the same yellowish
skin as seen in the second form
that made landfall while the dorsal
plates are barely formed
they are quite visible though the
biggest part was the very active tail
part that was easily over 14 to 20
meters long
but it is unknown however if this form
had any powers at all
the second form godzilla's second form
stands horizontally
with its body held parallel to the
ground this form had small stops in
place of arms
and huge eyes with small black pupils
unlike godzilla's later forms this form
possesses a sickly yellow
complexion with red exposed muscle on
its back and
shock like guilts that frequently bleed
showing that it struggles to breathe
outside the water and has a tail with a
fluke at the end of it like the first
form this form looks like it was
recently out of a hellish womb
and was crawling without any purpose or
direction however it was still big it
was 28 meters tall or 91 feet
the third form the third form of
godzilla is very much like traditional
incarnations in regards
to appearance this form is bipedal with
stronger more developed high limbs and
the ability to assume
a stance much like modern godzilla
possesses
smaller forms and a long neck compared
to its body
and in this form heat can be visibly
seen from its fins
meaning that its mutation consumes so
much energy and produce a lot of heat
its guilds also have shrunk and closed
up suggesting that this form
has now adapted to breathe on land
despite being bipedal its legs had not
very fully developed
causing it to noticeably shake while
walking
the fourth form this fourth form of shin
godzilla is very much akin to other
traditional designs
being fully bipedal with a fully
developed row of dorsal spines
and a much taller height in comparison
to its prior form
the shade of skin for this form is much
darker black color with red
glowing highlights around and those
exposed areas of the body such as its
neck
back and legs his hellish face has no
cheeks no lips
and multiple rows of jacket and gnarled
teeth that seem to jut out
from everywhere his eyes do not have any
eyelids although a protective nectating
membrane
sometimes form over them when he spews
out the thermal flame
and atomic breath but the most
noticeable change is the tail which was
easily twice as long as the entire body
the fifth form seen in the movie after
being forcefully fed with the blood
coagulant
shin godzilla went into an inanimate
stage in which his entire body shuts
down
but to fight humans he must evolve to be
like them and hence godzilla's fifth
form
takes on an eerily human shape with
godzilla-like dorsal plates running up
their spines
models for the evolution show that they
lack eyes despite
the concept art of the design originally
possessing them and a large divide
runs down their cranium like its
predecessor's form the humanoid forms
aren't muscular
and appears to be very emaciated with a
large hole present in their chest
which makes them look like deadly zombie
kaiju races
the proposed fifth form according to the
art of shin godzilla and several other
official publications shin godzilla was
to acquire the capability
of flight maybe with wings or shooting
his atomic breath
and propelling himself like a rocket who
knows he was proposed to undergo
self-division without limits to
eventually cover the entire planet
and with this divided forms he may
shrink in size and form a legion
becoming immune to the blood coagulant
plan as well as
lose sensitivity to pain and emotions he
could very well
undergo a self-generation of a completed
form from the tiniest fragment of the
body
if he was defeated so the evolutionary
strategy was to become a swarm species
of smaller godzillas
and take over the world interestingly it
was revealed in 2012 that a memo named
shin godzilla was left by ishiru honda
he was planning to create a godzilla to
self-divide and coalesce enemies and
grow larger
enabling verification and solidification
and the ability to become inanimate a
deleted scene within the film
features a slightly different take on
godzilla's continued adaptation and
mutation
in the scene the jsdf investigating
areas around the now dorman godzilla
finds a biomass
that was blown off from the monster and
this biomass
had developed eyes and teeth however the
creators of the film
thought that this idea would be too
disturbing to watch
the sixth form in this other form that
never
made it to the big screen godzilla was
planned to have overcome
requirements of air and water to survive
since we all know that godzilla was born
of radiation
he will have evolved to an extent that
he will achieve
at self-energy production and he arrives
that he will have achieved limitless
nuclear fusion
and thus overcome energy problems while
there is still a factor of consuming
hydrogen for fusion reactions
other plans for him was that along with
having energy independence
he would transform into a lovecraftian
entity that would eventually lose all
these organs and become a fleshy mars
with indescribable parts
in this stage he will eventually invade
outer space and other planets and start
to spread
his form of life to the stars the
seventh form
as he continues to expand and evolve to
survive the conditions of outer space
he will become a hive mind and know what
everything is happening around him
he would be able to survive any type of
harsh environments in all types of
planets
and space objects but the strangest
evolution of his is that he will be able
to synthesize any type of material
and elements at will to form out of
nowhere and also that due to this
he will be able to generate and contain
a small universe
within his body but even this will have
an end but as his evolution and purpose
is to never cease to exist and grow
and expand he will overcome this with
stage eight
the eighth form in his final form shin
godzilla is planned and theorized to
transcend physical law
and reaching the level of god and with
this he will attain immortality
not that vampire kind of immortality but
the omnipotent
omniscient and godlike immortality in
that he is omnipresent
in his own universe and everything that
evolves in it is a part of him
he would become the lovecraftian entity
called asitoth
a slumbering idiot god in that
everything that exists is because of his
dreams
in this final form he will be the
ultimate stage of life itself
and create new life if he so pleases and
so with this we come to the end of the
video
about the 8 forms of shin godzilla do
leave your thoughts down below
and leave a like and hit that
notification bell for more videos like
these